it is 1999 and I am attending a
residential high school there's girls
dorms there's the guys and the hormones
are real it was a guy
we were both students we started hanging
now along comes November we start making
out but then December comes and there's
like a week left of school before
Christmas break and keep in mind this is
1999 y2k is everywhere when the ball
drops New Year's Eve everyone is
preparing for the worst on haywire could
mean shortages of food water and
electricity they're prepared to survive
no matter what happened the end of the
world could be soon I seriously believed
it bombs going off from all the hidden
silos in the world security officials
are believed to be on the biggest alert
since World War two at that time you
didn't really fact-checked you just
believed with that came the fear I could
possibly die virgin it's they're making
too much out of it it's not gonna be
anything in study hall one night I
actually sent in my email that looks
like you know I was thinking about this
and you know we have like a week left
before we have to go home for break and
maybe we should you know take care of it
before you know the world that's kind of
sarcastic kind of not but he said okay
let's do this some of our favorite
makeout spots were these low bushes near
the library let's see oh there was a
graveyard
it was pure teenager anus I mean it
could have been Fort Knox
but there's horny kids and they're away
from their parents it's gonna happen we
escaped the dorms and we found this tree
had some awkward petting looking around
darting around making sure no one's
looking this is like the late 90s and
everything was NSYNC and Backstreet Boys
so you expected to like have him show up
with a rose and there to be this
earth-shattering kind of experience and
then it happened it wasn't great and it
wasn't bad but there were you know the
sensation of having tree roots and
branches pressed against your butt isn't
exactly romantic and like kind of laid
there in silence that was it went home
for Christmas break more people watched
that countdown than ever everyone young
it all was like oh are we about to die
but you know everything worked out we're
still alive and I continued our
relationship and earnest there's not
gonna be this huge explosion and
everyone will know about it don't put
too much pressure on it happening make
sure you're ready make sure you want it
go
[Music]
[Music]